yesterday afternoon we had this report
of an incident
off the coast of the united arab
emirates and then that was
upgraded to a potential hijack of this
tanker
the asphalt princess and we were told it
was boarded by a group of armed men
we were told they were linked to iran
and the the tanker then was directed
towards iran iran came out and said it
had
no involvement at this the embassy here
in the uk
said it had no information on even there
being an incident
and then today this news from the uk's
threat center
that looks at threats in the region
saying that the vessel
uh the boarding is over the people have
left the vessel
and the vessel is now safe and this all
comes
at a time of heightened tension
following a fatal
attack on an israeli-linked tanker last
thursday in which a british individual
was killed the uk came out quickly
blamed iran
for that that tanker attacked promised
a response we're waiting to see that
response but clearly yesterday's
incident
showing that very much tensions in that
region still and the
the threat is still very much evident